here we go duck game look at me oh yeah
don't fat but less oh your way through a
bunch of crap well isn't that just life
anyway let's go it's a quack button and
there's a whatever the [ __ ] that is
button breakdance button yeah look at me
Mom
Wow break all targets alright gameplay
oh how do i wreckages if [ __ ] don't
play energy - bro look at this [ __ ] ah
[ __ ]
alright now look at this MLG [ __ ] I am
this is like neo from the matrix and
except they're done I think that's the
[ __ ] am I even holding this ah
doh what are you shut up the [ __ ] is
Saturn doing there get the [ __ ] off me
Carson yeah jetpacks what are you doing
here JIT pic don't worry about it Doug
it's gonna be a
oh my god fly on the wings of duck just
face [ __ ]
this game is [ __ ] me I'm so into this
game I don't know if it's sad or awesome
dammit
am i tryharding goddammit nice fruits
breath
oh man their product well huh quack
quack quack quack oh whoa I can slide
and [ __ ] yeah
it regain reminds me of that hotline
miami a lot it's kind of like you keep
you keep [ __ ] up easily and when you
replay you do it like a [ __ ] boss for
drinks sauce look at my ass look at my
ass look at Mac he's out of ammo
now's your chance [ __ ] oh god you're
right duck you're right I see my
fabulous Oh
this game is amazing yes death ray 101
how nice yeah now we're talking now
alright good practice in practice how am
I gonna survive for a [ __ ] minute
that's just in react it's so sonic
inspired I [ __ ] love it
Sonic when Sonic was good of course can
we can we buy some cool hats oh I can
buy a hat yes
like what do I get I can bite Shah man
okay what's my husband
Oh
oh my god you get so many right up the
back sin Phi sin Phi hat yeah notice me
my head is huge
why would I denote Wow God how I say
guys that go John I got a [ __ ] change
I'm a duck with a change stop this is
the greatest moment of my life
yes here's a key whoa I'm gonna have to
take a break there I hope you enjoyed
this episode I had so much fun playing
such a cool game let me know if you want
more now is a great time to leave a like
leave a comment about ducks but
oh my god I'm back in the game stop walk
why we [ __ ] mob